ازمه امريكا مع النفط بدات مع دخول
الجوبايدن المكتبه البيضاوي قرر الرئيس
السادس والاربعون وقفه منحي تراخيص
واذونات جديده للتنقيب عن النفط والغاز في
الاراضي الفيدراليه مشكله اولى من صنع يد
الرئيس فاقمها بمشكله ثانيه قرار بضرب
مشروع انابيب كيستون الاستراتيجي مع كندا
الذي يستطيع نقل تقريبا نحو مليون برميل
يوميا الى ساحل خليج الولايات المتحده
اوقفه كما اشرنا ايضا بعد ان اجازه الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ضمن استراتيجيه
اداراته لتعزيز امن الطاقه في امريكا
اكثر من ذلك قاوم بعض الضغوط التي مارستها
كندا على الولايات المتحده لاحياء خط
انابيب كيستون اكس ال تعويضا عن الامدادات
الروسيه الخاضعه للعقوبات لكن لمشكله
النفط في الولايات المتحده جانب وسبب مزمن
ايضا
ليست كلها من صنع اخطاء بيضا الذي يعرف
عنه اصلا توجهه نحو الطاقات المتجدده
بموازاه استراتيجيه خفض الاستثمارات في
قطاع استخراج النفط وتكريره فالادارات
الامريكيه المتعاقبه في العقدين الماضيين
اهملت قضيه صيانه واستثمار مصافي تكرير
النفط
متلو بايدا يسر الديمقراطيون على
استراتيجيات تحديد سقف مرتفع لمواصفات
الوقود تتسبب بمشاكل في الامدادات وارتفاع
الاسعار بالطبع بالارقام ايضا تراجع عدد
المصافي 13 بالمئه خلال عشر سنوات رقم هو
الادنى
ارتفاع الاسعار في الولايات المتحده يعود
الى نقص القدره على تحويل النفط الى وقود
وبالتالي تراجع المعروض في السوق الداخليه
بالارقام شكل الهامش بين اسعار النفط
الخام والمنتجات المكرره نحو 20 دولارا
نقلتها الحرب الاوكرانيه الى عتبه السبعين
دولارات
عامل اخر يضع بثقله المعنوي العلاقه
السيئه بين بيض وشركات النفط الامريكيه
الجمهوريون يتهمون الرئيسه بالاضرار
بشركات النفط العملاقه واذ قال قدره
انتاجها بالضرائب المبالغ بها والقيود
القانونيه والتشريعيه اذا اضفنا الى سلسله
هذه المشاكل الداخليه عامل الطبيعه اعني
هنا الاعاصير التي تتسبب بتوقف مصافي
التكرير او تراجع قدرتي التكرير فيها ايضا
يعود انخفاض مخزون البنزين الى اغلاق
المصافي بحجه عدم ربحتها الكبيره لماذا لم
تعد مربحه بسبب القوانين البيئيه الصارمه
والضرائب كما اشعرنا فالمشكله اذا تقنيه
بحث لكنها لماذا اخذت هذا البعض والسجال
الذي وصل الى حد اتهام قرار اوبك كلاس
لا يتحمل بيض مسؤوليه اسعار الطاقه وفق
بلومبرج هناك عوامل عده متعلقه به لعب
دورا مهما خصوماته لشركات النفط وتعهده
بوقف استخدام الوقود الاحفوري ضمن مجموعه
من العوامل الاخرى طبعا افقدت قدره السوق
طاقه الامريكيه على التعامل بمرونه مع
صدمات الاسعار
لسوء حظي الرئيس
مع امتحان انتخابين لولايته في الثامن من
نوفمبر
سلاح سياسيا بوجه سلعه حيويه اقتصاديه بحث
ليس لامريكا فحسب بل للعلم